I SUGGEST YOU USE IT.
HE DIDN'T TAKE MY ADVICE.
JOINING US NOW, SENATOR LINDSAY
GRAHAM.
SENATOR, A LOT OF THIS FALLS NOW
ON YOUR SHOULDERS.
I SEE YOU LAUGHING, BUT --
>> I'VE ENJOYED LISTENING.
>> Sean: ANYTHING YOU HEARD ME
SAY THAT'S WRONG?
>> NO.
I MEAN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRY
THESE PEOPLE ON CABLE
TELEVISION.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT THROUGH
THE RULE OF LAW, RIGHT?
>> Sean: TOTALLY AGREE.
I BELIEVE IN DUE PROCESS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU'VE BEEN CONSISTENT ON
THAT.
DID THEY EXONERATE CLINTON
BECAUSE THEY HAD A POLITICAL
BIAS?
DID THEY IGNORE ALL THE FACTS
BECAUSE IF THEY INDICT HER THEY
KNOW SHE CAN'T BEAT TRUMP AND
THEY WANTED TRUMP TO LOSE.
WAS IT AT THAT DOORWAY OF SPYING
ON TRUMP.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF WORKING
WITH RUSSIA, THEY'RE JUST USING
IT AS AN EXCUSE.
WAS THE FISA WARRANT OBTAINED
UNLAWFULLY TO SURVEIL THE
CAMPAIGN.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
THINK YOU WANT TO KNOW ABOUT AND
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT.
>> Sean: TELL US THE STEPS YOU
WILL TAKE.
YOU WILL PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE
HERE, SIR.
>> FIRST THING I WANT TO DO IS
FIND OUT WHY THEY GOT A WARRANT
AGAINST CARTER PAGE IF THE
DOSSIER WAS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
WHAT DID YOU HAVE BEYOND THE
DOSSIER?
WHY DIDN'T YOU LISTEN TO BRUCE
ORR.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HOW COULD
YOU USE THIS DOCUMENT TO GET A
WARRANT ON FOUR DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS.
I WANT TO FIND OUT ALL ABOUT
THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW IF THE E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS BASICALLY
DROPPED BECAUSE THEY HAD A
POLITICAL BIAS.
I WANT TO KNOW IF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, WHY DIDN'T YOU
WARN TRUMP THAT YOU THOUGHT THE
RUSSIANS WERE TRYING TO
INFILTRATE HIS CAMPAIGN.
WHY DIDN'T --
>> Sean: YEAH, HE'S A PATRIOT --
RIGHT.
>> THE REASON I THINK THEY
DIDN'T TELL HIM ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS INFILTRATED HIS
CAMPAIGN, THEY WANTED TO
INFILTRATE HIS CAMPAIGN, NOT THE
RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I KNOW YOU
HAVE -- BY THE WAY, THERE ARE A
LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN ALL OF
THIS.
MEADOWS AND JORDAN AND ALL THESE
PEOPLE.
YOU NOW HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
PUBLIC AND THE PRESIDENT WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE PUBLIC
THE FISA WARRANTS, THE 302s, THE
GANG OF EIGHT INFORMATION.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
>> Sean: AND THESE OTHER
BUCKETS -- THE FIVE BUDGE
BUCKETS -- THE FIVE BUCKETS I
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT IT.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THAT BESIDES
THE MUELLER, YOU KNOW,
CONCLUSIONS?
>> I'VE BEEN PRETTY CONSISTENT.
I SAID I THOUGHT MUELLER WAS THE
RIGHT GUY TO LOOK INTO THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE WAS A MAN OF THE LAW.
HE HAD A GREAT REPUTATION, AND I
FOUGHT TO MAKE SURE HE COULD DO
HIS JOB.
HE HAS RENDERED HIS VERDICT.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
NOW IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT HOW
THIS GOT OFF THE RAILS.
I'M GOING TO USE EVERY TOOL
AVAILABLE TO ME, DISCLOSE AS
MUCH AS I CAN WITHOUT
COMPROMISING SOURCE AND METHODS
TO MAKE SURE THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS HOW THEIR PRESIDENT
COULD BE ACCUSED OF WORKING WITH
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT WHEN
THERE'S NO BASIS IN FACT.
THIS SHOULD SCARE EVERYBODY.
DID THE INVESTIGATORS, DID THE
PROSECUTORS USE THE LAW FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES?
IF THAT TURNS OUT TO BE TRUE,
THAT IS BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
DID THEY TRY TO TAKE HIM DOWN
AFTER HE GOT ELECTED?
WAS THERE A REAL EFFORT TO
INVOKE THE FIFTH AMENDMENT.
NOBODY SEEMS TO GIVE A DAMN BUT
ME AND YOU AND A FEW OTHER
PEOPLE.
IF IT HAD BEEN REPUBLICANS
HIRING STEELE TO SPY ON CLINTON
AND USED A DOSSIER PREPARED BY
STEELE AGAINST CLINTON
ASSOCIATES THAT WAS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE, IT WOULD BE FRONT
PAGE --
>> Sean: RUSSIAN LIES.
>> I THINK SO.
I TOLD TRUMP THAT.
I THINK THE DOSSIER CAME FROM
RUSSIA.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU THINK THE
RUSSIANS ARE JUST OUT TO HELP
YOU?
THEY'RE NOT, THEY'RE OUT TO
DESTROY AMERICA.
THEY'RE USING BOTH CAMPAIGNS.
>> Sean: YOU REALLY HAD A MOMENT
IN THE KAVANAUGH CASE.
A LOT WEIGHS ON YOUR
INVESTIGATION AND YOUR PLEDGE